opening are you expecting david
i'm thinking he's going to push his
queen spawn on the first go when aronian
has beaten giri in the past and i should
mention he's beaten giri a lot
their matchup's very very one-sided
but when he has beaten geary it's
normally through attacking him from the
off and uh avoiding maybe mainstream
opening battles he knows that inish is
fantastic in the opening he should guide
the game uh he normally tries to guide
the game towards a sharp
kind of complex very tense positions
with lots of pieces on the board i
remember looking at their stats uh from
over-the-board chess a couple of years
ago and
it was just incredible i think he'd
beaten gary
more than a dozen times and gary had
nearly never beaten him
so um yep this matchup i think will
favor irony if he can get out of the
opening in good shape and giri is known
for hardly ever losing games especially
in classical chess so levonaroni and a
little bit of his nemesis
quite possibly yeah quite possibly
sometimes you know you know regardless
of how strong we are we always have that
one opponent that you know just gets
under our skin somehow the luck never
goes our way and uh yeah we will see
whether anish will manage to uh actually
stabilize
and uh i know anish
when talking about nemesis uh jordan van
forest yeah
for many years has also been another one
of those uh opponents he just can't
manage to score against and okay we've
kicked off it's not been a queens born
instead we've seen a sicilian so lebron
consistently going for the approach he
took in game two yeah and you mentioned
the scars of that defeat against arjuna
regaici
aronian he's not letting that affect him
he's repeated the exact same opening we
saw a couple of games ago
but anish gary has chosen a different
setup for black so black now has
fianceed his bishop his darts go bishop
black's king side structure there rock
solid
and iranian how is he going to sharpen
up this game how is he going to bring it
to life he develops his bishop white
wants to step the queen forward one
square on the next go maybe centralize
the white rooks and only wait until
later to open up the center
this is not regarded as the most
ambitious approach for white it's not
maybe regarded as the most active or
correct approach but it's very much
directed at the
time format first of all the rapid
format it means that anish is on his own
already he wouldn't have studied this
for sure uh but also it's directed at
the opponent he knows a niche opening
specialist won't be able to use anything
he's studied in the past it's just about
understanding now putting pieces on good
squares
seizing the moment later on the game
might sharpen up later your anchor yeah
uh definitely we'll sharpen up later um
for me you know just looking at the pawn
structure looking at the pieces i'm
thinking that the issue is actually on
this light square bishop that white has
sitting there on the c4 square because
normally it's tucked behind the pawn
chain it's not really a target
and uh can black for instance
try and trade it off yeah start chasing
it already yeah maybe bring the knight
to the edge of the board
attacking this bishop this would be very
very logical and actually you can't
really avoid the knight for bishop
exchange right because if the bishop
runs away from the exchange you only
help black
push pawns forward you kick this bishop
you kick it back once again and this
bishop eventually will get traded off
for a night um i'm very surprised aneesh
didn't go for that however um
maybe he just thought aronia will ignore
this and a night for bishop exchange
it's not clear who this helps because
suddenly white gets a semi-open file on
the
uh white has two very strong pawns here
kind of keeping control over the light
squares but instead anish just pushed a
pawn and this is not kind of uh
usually advised because this pawn could
be a big target i think the idea if
white had pushed the queen forward
attacking this pawn twice now is that
black can slide the king across and
defend this square
however watch out for this to be a
weakness later this black pawn
and aronian meanwhile decided okay let's
just slide the rook across hinting at
opening up the center anish has to
decide whether to allow a pawn push here
or whether to lock it down
quite a typical idea in this type of
position would be to push a pawn forward
it looks a bit anti-positional but you
gain time against the white bishop okay
he's done this and when the white bishop
retreats i'm expecting this direction
because if you retreated the other way
you're just staring against a very well
fortified wall of pawns
but yet when the bishop retreats i'm
expecting at some point maybe ivanka's
idea go for this bishop or offer a trade
of your own bishop and play very much
becomes a
type of italian game a slower type of
maneuvering
position but it's not a bad one for
black black has a lot of control over
some key squares yeah
it does feel like it's going to be a
battle between white's long-term
trumps which is kind of like good pieces
also good control over the light squares
versus black's very flexible pawn
structure you know he has a possibility
should he wish to to try to trade off
some pieces and also maybe initiate some
play
you could definitely imagine that yeah
jumping out the way exactly throwing
some points forward as you mentioned
very flexible and this structure we've
been talking about world champions a lot
today but this is known as the bot vinic
type of pawn structure you can have it
with reverse colors from the english
opening and uh it looks odd because
there's kind of a hole in the middle
there's an outpost for white piece to
sit on but the key is that you stop any
white pawn breaks so you stop white from
ever advancing forward in the center and
uh okay now anjiri he wants to advance
on every flank possible he wants to push
this pawn forward to
maybe join its fellow pawns there in on
the fifth rank but also to gain time
against the bishop
you could definitely imagine a situation
where okay the knight jumps in now but
you could imagine a situation where if
white is too slow uh then the black
knight will retreat and for example look
at all these black pawns pushing forward
gaining space and white is very very
cramped
that's beauty
i love that position for black um yeah
and yeah i think because white is scared
of getting cramped and all the black
pawns pushing forward uh if you're
lacking space exchange off a set of
pieces
but downside your anchor is that after a
night trade
suddenly you could definitely imagine
black's pawns pushing forward opening up
some lines now the black rook uh sitting
on a grape file yeah potentially totally
um yeah i
i would do this in a heartbeat i don't
think i would pause too much for that
um also black has the opportunity to
expand as you mentioned you know to have
it all you know he can push that pawn
whenever he wants to when they come on
the right side but also you know why not
grab as much as you can on the left yeah
as well gain some time against this
bishop yep that would be very logical um
i know magnus carlsen he's he loves this
type of pawn structure as black in the
sicilian in the
uh spanish opening in various different
structures and i was gonna say he will
take this knight off in a heartbeat and
he will either push this pawn now or
maybe he'll gain some time against this
bishop first kick this bishop back
somewhere uh and only now push forward
with this pawn magnus loves this type of
thing as black he's rock solid in this
in the center and then he'll start
initiating play
on one side of the board
um yeah i've seen many examples of this
type of thing happen before it's not
it's not to say that black has got the
advantage or black is doing well
necessarily but black has a clear plan
for white it's less clear maybe white's
idea is to just ignore everything that's
going on over there and push his own
pawns to try and destabilize black's
stronghold on c5 so
interesting game ahead yeah definitely i
mean
i i have to say you know i think white's
position seems very unnatural you know
is that the plans that you highlighted
there
it takes some courage to just ignore all
the action that's happening in the
center and just go well you know what
i'm just going to play on the left and
confuse you a little bit um so i i i
like anish's position quite
significantly
and uh
i'm trying to i have to have to say one
of my
like pet hobbies is to watch these two
ah it's on the board is to watch players
in their natural habitats in their homes
and uh
it just seems to be that lavon is
not 100
well comfortable and i say that and he's
played the plan that you uh highlighted
destabilize the center
so you said that before he played
before yeah but uh has the opinion
changed now that he played that move so
quickly and look at the clock times he's
very speedy is that confidence or is
that false confidence from level iranian
yeah this this is the thing you know he
is these guys play amazing chess so that
does inspire me to trust them a little
bit
quite a bit actually and uh well hang on
a second there's been a few committal
decisions
just now i mean i'm not sure about uh
pushing that pawn forward and just
locking down the tension yeah anish
geary playing very quickly this last
move i'm looking at his air quality as
well looks decent very warm over there
uh in the netherlands but yeah very
committal decision you mentioned yeah
and black's pawns pushing forward the
center is now completely closed again
but black has gained space is he going
to launch a pawn storm against the uh
against the white king
that's that's what you would that's what
i would think
yeah you know
you've you've pushed white you pushed
the f-pawn why not go forward with the
g-pawn and the edge pawn and
you know
yeah no
he's changed
okay so maybe he's kind of saying
let's solidify
the left side before we even think about
initiating operations on the right and
maybe one downside behind pushing these
pawns firstly it takes a long time as
black you need to go step by step to
push pawns towards the white king
i mean this would have been logical to
me but one of the downsides is that
white's pawn can now push forward and
now this black pawn is fixed it's what
we call a backward pawn it can never
match forward without being captured and
if it ever does march forward uh it will
just simply get taken and black is left
with two weak isolated pawns on the side
of the board um if you don't step this
pawn forward meanwhile he'll just be a
clear target for white's rook tying down
the black bishop at home on its start
square so uh it makes some sense what
anisha has just done pushing his pawn
forward and levon says okay it's still a
weakness i'm still going to target it
and it's okay i was gonna say it's
surely time for anish to just ignore the
side of the board now and initiate his
attack by pushing pawns but no he moves
his queen first aneesh is a
perfectionist by nature he wants
everything to be nice and pretty before
he starts attacking
but it feels a bit slow this queen uh
this queen advance i would have just
rushed i think
um i'm not sure about you ivanka just
push this pawn forward maybe bring the
knight this direction
patience is not my virtue either you
know so i would have also rushed for the
pawns but you know
but the reason i like this queen on the
d8 square is because for example if
let's say uh white moves the bishop now
you move the knight now the queen
actually protects this pawn so you're
ready to push forward with h5 and then
ready to throw all the black pawns
towards the white king now where the
queen stands
suddenly if you push this pawn it's not
defended by a black queen ever and look
at what level neroni has done he's
getting ready to throw pawns forward in
the center to explode open the position
on the next go
i mean looks like black is defending
this square so many times four times
two pawns and two pieces defending the
square but aronian is not caring at all
he wants to open things up and also this
pawn it is attacked it is vulnerable but
if it gets captured suddenly the black
queen would lose protection of this uh b
pawn so white's rook now would just be
too strong yeah as a critical moment you
know as you've highlighted why it's
threatening to blast open the center
alternatively maybe even start looking
at that weak pawn so two weaknesses um
difficult difficult to react to that one
actually
i mean somehow are they you would like
the light square bishop to be
somewhere on the board just not where it
is this black lights
for example if we go back again i'm
being too critical of any guerrillas
moves here but um if you push forward if
now white does the same then at least
you can make an argument for pushing
your pawn again
and suddenly your bishop stands on a
great square i guess there are some
tactics here the white knight could jump
out the way with a check it gets a bit
complicated but this type of thing at
least you have a potential home at some
point for your bishop
i'm just worried in the current position
levon aronian maybe i'm just influenced
by the speed with which he's playing 50
more than 15 minutes still
um and getting ready to explode things
open um if the position does open up and
if levon has a five minute time
advantage only going to go in one way
niche yeah spending uh a lot of time
again on this move and uh well
levonironian known to be a big gentleman
in the world of uh chess
but we do love ourselves a little bit of
drama and uh we're gonna talk about that
but first let this move uh yeah really
interesting move
in the current position anish giri
decides okay he's pushed this pawn
forward one square two moves ago he's
going to push it forward again wow it
looks like all the top players are
forgetting that pawns can move two
squares forward on their first go but
the reason is now that the white rook
has been lured away to this square um
the white bishop is undefended uh so for
example if we see an exchange then white
doesn't have time to win this pawn
because actually his bishop is attacked
on a2 so rook takes pawn would be met by
rook takes bishop winning a piece and
that means that if you want to trade
pawns um sorry all my arrows there you
have to move your bishop out the way
first or defend it so this would cost
aronian some time
all right well now he's thinking
levonoronyan and i'm just going to bring
us back a few months in time there was a
big twitter drama in the chess world
someone hacked anish geary's twitter
account
and we're going to talk about the
response from lavon
ironian uh
because uh
he implied in this tweet i think
that anichigiri wasn't hacked
that
it was anish himself
who wrote those tweets referring to a
colombo episode where
well the murderer
tries to help the police
i was very surprised when i saw this
tweet by lavon he usually always stays
away from the big drama were you
surprised when you saw this david i was
extremely surprised and uh
yeah i mean i'm not i'm still not sure
what to say to this uh to be honest most
of the top guys they kind of kept their
opinions private they didn't react to
the the all the hacking and everything
that went on or the fallout
but uh yeah i must say i've seen a lot
of colombo episodes it's pretty much
every episode uh columbus detective
colombo ends up befriending the
uh the criminal the criminal the victim
slash criminal and uh finding out but
yeah i mean i'm not sure what anish
thinks about this i'm not sure whether
there's been any bad blood between them
since
um either way
it could be motivation for an issue yeah
try and get revenge and trying and show
show lev on whose boss here but
yeah i mean what else is there to say
it's uh still yeah very touchy subject i
think yeah yeah i mean but talking about
anish you know recently he was in madrid
with magnus and
other members of the play magnus group
like young gustafsson judy pogba and
they got along fine yeah so i mean
presumably
it's it's probably okay they're dropping
water under the bridge yeah you know
these these things do happen when it
comes to hacking and also not being
hacked or i don't know it's it's a
complicated scenario yeah but uh okay we
do have uh
an interesting move from
on because out of all the moves i was
not expecting that one
to retreat the bishop to the starting
square
switch
angles i nope
it's just didn't cross my mind it's as
if these top players are just showing
off now it's just they think they can
get away with anything they can break
all the rules they can move upon one
square forward next move move it again
um they can retreat their pieces to
their starting squares
as you've mentioned it's just changing
angle changing direction and if we jump
in we can see why this mysterious bishop
move was made and this bishop actually
gets in the way i think that's the issue
he gets in the way of the queen the
queen wants to support her pawn on the
d3 square and maybe wants to support it
pushing forward and by retreating the
bishop now the queen does support this
pawn for example pawn to d4 is
definitely on the cards on the next turn
exploding open the center if that does
happen also the bishop stepping back
as well as that pawn push you could see
the bishop
land on this diagonal and actually has a
whole bunch of targets
if it does find this square so
really really clever whether it's good
or not i'm not so sure
this is definitely not a game that i'll
be showing any students though you know
trying to figure out the rules of chess
where to put your pieces how to push
pawns
no no no but
interesting stuff nonetheless i think
gary's problem though is what to do you
want to as your man mentioned improve
this bishop
okay you want to improve it but how
that's the question instead he moves his
rook across defending this pawn but that
feels a bit slow and is now the moment
for levon aronian to explode things open
in the center
i think it might be black is not
completed development white pieces look
a bit clumsy
but if you throw your pawn forward in
the center after a whole bunch of
exchanges it just feels like after this
pawn push black's queen is just getting
kicked around and suddenly wherever she
goes wherever she hides white queen
might uh land on a decent diagonal soon
the white bishop might come out to this
diagonal maybe this was his plan all
along
at the very least you could recapture
this pawn in the center that you
sacrificed just a couple of moves ago
it's double-edged but it looks good for
white it looks great for to white to my
eyes especially because say the queen's
come off in this final kind of position
you can just see that uh
very strong central pawn that white has
it's just going to control and dominate
the game yeah this pawn just looks
fantastic and yeah it could well push
forward on the next few moves
looking good for iranian yep certainly
looking good and
whilst aronian is considering whether to
bite the bullet and just just uh launch
that pawn forward
well
we can see that lavon is playing from
his home in armenia but okay he's gone
for it
yeah big big move the game's speeding up
livening up
and probably in iranian's favor still a
big time advantage as well three extra
minutes on the clock
yep
definitely and i was just going to show
you know this is a very exciting game
and it's really nice to share everyone's
watching from home their excitement how
they're following the show and we have
cosmond who is watching from barcelona
oh whilst cutting some jamon well enjoy
the good food and uh okay so we have a
trade of pawns
and uh the line that you mentioned david
is probably going to occur
white has to push the pawn and attack
the queen
what else to do yeah push it forward
very logical gain time quite strong
yeah
spring forward with the pawn and okay so
levon doing good things you know he's
taking his time not being too rash
but he should do that and then smans
magna litto is also watching us from
home from south africa oh and is also
cheering for mama jaroff and okay the
porn has stepped forward attacking the
queen
and anish
decides to move the queen to the c5
square just there keeping contact with
the black pawn in the middle of the
board yeah actually i think this is a
much stronger move than the one i
suggested in the previous variation
because now the white bishop the white
dart squad bishop cannot go to the edge
of the board onto that fantastic
diagonal
now the black queen controls that key a3
square so white's bishop at the bottom
of the board now struggling to find a
good diagonal
so temporarily black is one pawn up
maybe we can show just one variation
that i i'm not so sure level iranian
should be tempted by but if he does for
example capture this pawn in the center
with his queen
then after a coin trade then i think
white still has the advantage but the
pressure has lessened slightly and with
queens off the board at least black can
hope for a situation where he can maybe
give up a pawn and survive a difficult
end game
i do think that maybe level ironian just
style wise his best chances lie in the
middle game
here actually the more i look at it the
more i think it's great for white uh
white still has this very strong protect
uh this very strong past pawn and
there's also a target on the b5 square
uh thanks to this pin on the b file but
uh yeah in the meantime black's piece is
just not great not active at all i was
going to say that this might be a
mistake but maybe this still maintains a
safe advantage instead
if he wants to be more ambitious and
maybe more
characteristic of levon aronian would be
to maybe move his bishop out the way
take this pawn with a bishop gaining
time keeping the queens on the board but
also getting ready to gain time using
the rook trying to attack the queen and
maybe break through to the seventh rank
if possible
it's very very sharp right now this
would be the risky option keeping the
queens on the board but higher risk
higher reward potentially
if he wants to play it safe levon he
might trade off the queens by taking
this pawn back now oh we should take a
bet what's what what do you think he's
going to go i think he'll keep the
queens on i think he's going to keep the
queens on as well okay but i have to go
opposite so you know
you can bet on the same
[Laughter]
oh okay this doesn't necessarily change
too much he trades off a set of pawns
here i'm assuming anishigiri is going to
take back with a pawn
you could make an argument for taking
with the rook potentially but uh
structure-wise this pawn is maybe not as
good as a potential pawn
on the b-file compared to now where it's
further advanced maybe stronger
yeah
but uh when it comes to
like this rook trade you know it's quite
a key moment for me because
you know it would that rook sitting on
b1 be a sleeping giant like it might not
be great now
but later on you showed some lines where
rook could possibly come into the
seventh row and that one could be the
culprit yeah and uh yeah you're right
maybe now trading you might not have a
great pawn here that isolated pawn but
okay he does take with the pawn but
trading off these rooks would be maybe a
small gain for black uh here ivanka just
in the theme of putting pieces back on
their starting squares would ironian put
his rook back in the corner threatening
maybe some bishop jumps to this long
diagonal uh using the rook indirectly to
protect this square
that would have been cool seeing a
bishop retreat to a scarce square and
then this piece back to its start square
but uh okay we don't have that dilemma
to face pawn takes pawn was played and
it's our bet again yep on the board
you were right
you might ever want to bet against you i
think you have
if i have it might have been one bet
you've won about 100 now
you need to hire ivanka to choose our
lottery numbers
[Laughter]
well i was actually doing the same with
my co-commentator norway chest you know
and i would win as well yeah it just
goes to show you know i just think this
intuition and uh there was no
calculation behind my
it was just well going for opposite
david yeah that was it intuition is good
but uh meanwhile so levon neverend he
has taken the safe approach offering
this queen exchange okay first there was
next uh kind of a trade of pawns which
doesn't change the nature too much
but
anish giri he needs to find a solution
once the queens do come off and i think
they will come off he needs to get the
black pieces active
black bishop light squared bishop still
at home asleep that's dark squared
bishop just pointing against a very
strong white pawn black's knight not on
a great circuit
and you just have to take the queens off
surely
no he doesn't take the queens off the
board but this black queen is in no
man's land now and she's going to lose a
lot of time
totally um
i'm shocked by this one i must say
um i thought queen's coming off was a
guarantee maybe anish didn't want to
suffer in a kind of position where
he's only playing for a draw it would
have been a two result game a white win
or a draw if the queens had come off
here by keeping the queens on he wants
to play for three results but
this is playing with fire the white
bishop
dark square bishop could move the white
rook can step up one square attacking
the black queen you gain so much time
against this queen either way
yeah i have to say it was
my natural instinct to actually just
move the dark square bishop
you know line it up with a queen and
then start using the other
one of those rooks to just come in and
start taking control of the open sea
line
it looks great
for lavon
and uh it feels like anish just
desperate to keep the queens on the
board he's gonna kind of give away two
or three tempe two or three moves
just to achieve that and in chess that's
not really how it works every move has
such a high price
and yeah we see the evaluation bar did
react as well and sometimes we disagree
with the evaluation bar but here i think
we can understand why
i think anishi just made that move for
psychological decision uh reasons for
practical decisions
uh
yeah for i know for a fact if this was
over the board chess classical time
control he would have traded the queens
and just defended that or tried to
defend that in-game and iranian
counter-attacking yeah nice little
counter-attack there
i like that move actually
okay yes it changes the nature of the
position new suddenly black will have
might have two bishops against a bishop
in the night but white's porn is so
strong
yeah what's central born that is the
potential killer right that's the
potential key to the position and just
to show what's just happened we were
shocked that
levon oh sorry the english giri didn't
trade off the queens firstly i shocked
that level on irony and offered the
queen trade and i was even more shocked
that anish didn't take it off the board
at least here maybe you can hope to
defend the same game even if you lose a
pawn
as black at least all the pawns will be
on one side of the board
still no easy breakthrough for white but
uh keeping the queens on allowed levon
aronian not to attack the black queen as
i thought he might with a rook uh
stepping forward but counter-attacking
ignoring the threat against this bishop
in order to create a counter threat
against this undefended knight so queen
takes bishop now would simply be met by
bishop takes knight a fair exchange and
suddenly
after the black rook moves i think this
is just going to end in disaster for
black if you look at the black king only
one defender around it and that defender
is about to be traded off on the next
turn
this would be disastrous also black's
queen miles away from anywhere useful
uh instead what else finishing in the
current position do you defend this
knight maybe you can move the knight
attacking the white queen well we'll
level her onion put his queen then
yeah
that was that that was a nice option
where does this queen go i mean uh this
bishop is still under fire as well
do you step one square forward but then
you walk into an attack from this black
bishop which finally moves
uh gaining time
or maybe you can just offer a queen
trade since now you're for the queen
trade yeah going back this way maybe
okay
yeah and uh i guess you have activated
this bishop you are gaining time against
the black rook if the queens do
disappear
and anish clearly trying to avoid the
queen exchange maybe levon will force
that queen trade in this manner i was
also wondering if you could keep the
queens on with a move like this one
dropping it back into the corner just
with this nice weird formation but uh
yeah it looks like at least from what we
can see right now this is anish's best
try
maybe you can move the knight in the
other direction to attack the white
queen as well maybe there's an argument
for this one
yeah i thought the knight wasn't not
that stable so i was looking at radical
moves like you know actually being
really flashy and pushing the pawn
forward with the same idea going
hoping for maybe bishop takes and then
it doesn't work ah
this would maybe be okay but uh it
wouldn't work here i guess for
well i'm not sure why wouldn't it work
i don't know i i was thinking too many
pieces are hanging yeah it feels a bit
weird for black like this queen is
disconnected from her army this knight
is loose this rook is undefended
but uh still some hope so anish giri in
the current position um is this one
after the bishop moves he needs to deal
with this knight he needs to move it or
defend it
and just as you say ivanka you should
really guess the move every game if you
push the phone look at that the bars
like i was losing you should not have
played that at all
it's a human solution to a difficult
problem yeah okay so so why does the bar
hate it so much
so there must be a refutation so both
bishops are under attack right now this
bishop and maybe this bishop as well
yeah and uh
yeah how do you deal with it i mean
first thing that comes to my mind would
be okay levon actually moves this bishop
i was gonna say step forward with the
rook um hitting the queen at least
guarding one bishop but levon guards one
bishop by gaining time and also hitting
the queen and wherever the queen goes
again i'm not sure sure where really if
it retreats for example maybe now you
can either consider taking this pawn
using some tactics or you could just
step back and these bishops still on
great squares
it's unclear i'm surprised the
evaluation bar is so far in white's
favor but maybe there's something very
strong here maybe in the current
position uh attacking this queen maybe
at some point this pawn is just going to
drop yeah
and also as you kind of called it a few
moves earlier that black queen is going
to get chased around the board as well
and with every time that she does it she
it's going to be white improving the
pieces so i don't see a safe square for
the black queen yeah essentially maybe
the black queen can go
kind of back along the diagonal
it's the f5 square but
it just feels a bit clumsy and like you
said it just feels a bit loose uh
black's position
and also clock times a niche he's not
great in time pressure compared to some
of his
some of his kind of elite rivals
so three minutes that is very very scary
times for anishikari fans yeah and uh he
retreats his queen
probably to a safer square but this
does allow
some captures and uh goodness me
lavon is playing super quickly yeah
levon irony and trusting his instincts
and white's bishop has fallen but he got
a knight in return and also remember
that black b pawn it's dropped it's off
the board
and
wow is level of ronin just not thinking
is he kind of levitating the pieces the
mouse because
he reacted instantly to anishigiri's
attack on his queen he dropped back the
black rook now under fire
isn't the root gonna fall
yeah i mean bishop the big threat is for
the bishop to the light square bishop to
swoop all the way and give a check to
the black king
how do you get off that poisonous bee
line you can't yeah you have we have to
show this ivanka because uh in the
current position if as you mentioned the
rook is attacked if you drop back then
this piece is loose
that is a check getting the bishop out
of the way gaining time against the
black king and when the bishop is
captured white has time to go and grab
the black rook
but the reason i'm so surprised that
level neronian is not even pausing is
because here retreating his queen it was
a very sensible move but there are for
example captures such as this one
taking a knight off the board and if
white gets greedy and takes the rook
then suddenly the black queen slides
across and whoops i think actually white
is the one struggling now to stop
checkmate this looks very very strong
for black
if you can't take this rook you have to
go and take the bishop yes you're doing
well yes you have an extra pawn but the
game continues
yeah black at least opposite color
bishops has some chances to save the
draw
can we see the players though we have to
go back to the players because i think
this is the only move bishop takes
knight
how else are you going to survive has
anishigiri seen this
he was shaking his head a moment ago yep
he's found it and the computer confirms
absolutely only move
and uh yeah the rook has to slide away
to the center get off the poisonous bee
line and uh yeah
white has a past pawn but as david
mentioned
black will have all control of the dark
squares and of course will have the
ability he's always hoping to establish
a fortress on the dark squares
yeah big threat the one you mentioned
same tactic uh the white bishop wants to
jump out the way with the check and the
black rook on the b4 square is loose it
would drop off
so big big threat in the position and
he's shaking his head as well meanwhile
what to do
do you have to move this black rook to a
safe square do you have to use the other
black rook to defend it
he needs to do something and you should
be one minute pawn down but oh look at
him he looks devastated but
fight you just got to fight yes it's a
bad position yes it's a difficult one
but
yeah you've got to show some resilience
okay i like your suggestion of doubling
the rooks it's an active move and you
know
black can live on in the hope there's
opposite color bishops and maybe a trade
of everything could happen okay instead
he moves the rook to a safe square
and
now
it's a case of if i were white i would
be thinking about
just re-routing the bishop to a even
better diagonal but first this is nice
to push the pawn
too tempting that white pawn stepping
forward it's two squares away from
promotion it's going to paralyze at
least one of the black rooks
one of blacks is going to act as a
blockader now
but how does white break through that's
the question
as ivanka mentions actually that i think
you're right you need to at some point
uh re
kind of
uh recirculate your bishop onto the same
diagonal as the black queen and the
black king okay first offering a trader
rooks off i'm not so sure
about this if you imagine the queen's
coming off all the rooks coming off
opposite-colored bishops that might well
be a draw yeah so
okay yes you're exchanging off black's
most active rook but
you're kind of helping black get some
pieces off the board at least
yeah that's that is true and the hope
the hope factor increases for a niche
but at the same time he's still treading
a very narrow path to safety yeah it's
the hope that kills you that's what i've
been taught you get a glimmer of hope
and then it's ripped away and
okay
okay a small trick from anish giri now
the black queen is actually staring down
at one of the white rooks so if white's
other rook moves black's queen will come
down and capture a rook with check
so uh just setting a small trap there no
rook exchange yet for white that would
be a huge blunder by levon ironian but
okay he's trying to force one rook off
the board and he's going to achieve that
both white rooks are staring down at
this black rook in the center
rook exchange is guaranteed now
yeah it's going to be so hard to build a
fortress on the dark squares uh as black
yeah i mean i think it might have been
possible if uh
black had all their pawns on uh
on the light squares i'm just thinking
of some kind of blockade
but as it stands you know there's a soft
point on the g6 square that's a little
bit loose also if you look at that one
remaining black pawn in the white half
of the board
yeah it's not really defensible long
term
yeah and you can't be two pawns down
yeah two pawns will be too much so a
rook trade white's queen steps back to
recapture and uh
well
it's going to be one side of traffic
definitely it's going to be threats
galore and
yeah looking bad for a niche gear in
this game i have to mention also it's
looking bad for timor ajaba in his game
against zhu and jun soju may be getting
her first win in the tournament and
actually timor ajabov uh he is one of
the higher seeded players with the
biggest drop
so far to make it to the knockout stage
whilst the jeffrey chung and arjun
ergaisi are both now among top four who
are most likely to qualify so already we
are seeing some big changes and we also
saw a move in this game yeah and he's at
least protecting everything threatening
the white rook he's trying to coordinate
the black army now if the black rook can
for example sit on a dark square
protected by its bishop everything will
protect each other he's going to curl up
into a little ball and he shouldn't try
to try to hold uh try to say it to lev
on you will not pass you shall not pass
but uh
yeah i feel silly picking rajabov as my
favorite for the tournament now he's
struggling really struggling and he
really is struggling yeah that would be
a great result for and jun if she can uh
finish him off yeah
well we have seen today a lot of the
favorites struggling a little bit anish
geary definitely one of those players
yeah and uh levon ironian struggling
first two games losing
now
what do you think of anchor second win
on the bounce i think so
this is looking like a good position and
also when i look at the clock situation
i mean come on any uh levon has uh just
over six minutes whilst anish
30 seconds
that's uh not that much time yeah he
should be able to find the kind of
killer touch to this uh game to end all
resistance at some point it just might
not be in the next few moves
as you mentioned yeah he'll build up the
threats he'll set the traps
aneesh with 30 seconds in a really
difficult position he might be able to
ward off the first
wave or two of the attack but long term
it shouldn't be enough yeah he can make
a few non-moves as well just to
stabilize the situation
yeah
i mean he has all the time in the world
you know i'm just thinking you know like
like you kind of suggest like over
protect everything keep it up in a ball
curl up on a ball and then slowly just
slowly kind of switch diagonals with the
bishop and uh
okay so
he
okay he moves his q i didn't want the
queen to go there
i wanted to go into over protection mode
the white queen yeah i i guess he's
maybe
setting a small trap in the position um
if we do jump in uh i mean anish giri
now setting a small trap it looks like
white's about to win a second pawn he
can play rook takes pawn here
he doesn't do that he takes with the
queen this would have allowed a check a
nasty check and after the king moves
suddenly a nasty skewer uh a pin on this
on this file on this line but uh instead
levon saw this of course and he said
nope i'm not going to fall into that
trap i'm going to take your pawn with my
queen instead allowing the queens off
the board that's not ideal but it is a
two-pawn advantage and
does black have a fortress the answer
should be no black is two pawns down and
more importantly this rook is extremely
extremely passive
so in the current position it looks like
sooner or later
why will improve the king white will
improve the rook where it will improve
the bishop and eventually the fortress
should fall
yeah yes it does look like that way but
still at the same time
i'm thinking in terms of the clock
situation it's now very easy for a niche
to make some non moves
yeah that's
that's great for an ishgiri he can just
wait with his bishop now
forever but
level iranian is coming with the king
mm-hmm
that is a lot of moves for the king yeah
it's a it's a snake that's not a king
it's a serpent king okay so the rook
comes forward two squares you know
that's a nice kind of idea just to
give a few checks and uh well levon just
carries on
with the threats moving his work to an
open line and uh okay there's nothing
funny to do other than just switch
backwards and forwards with the bishop
in order just to hold the position tight
you know he's not looking at anything
ambitious it's just
maintenance mode
yep and meanwhile level iranian pushing
pawns what do you think of this one
this pawn push is a bit committal it is
a committal i've learned that you've got
to be a bit cautious about pushing pawns
you don't need to rush with it you can
torture your opponents for a lot of
moves before you can make that uh
commitment
yeah it's a big commitment for white and
now the reason i don't like this pawn
push is because you can't check the
black king black's king is on a really
safe square
and um
yeah
and uh it's very difficult
it's very difficult to check the king as
david mentioned and also it's uh very
difficult for pieces to come forward and
just penetrate because what
levon needs to do is just create two
weaknesses he needs to over stretch and
each gary and he has a lot of time to uh
to find the moves that he needs to find
to win which is why he didn't need to
rush with the such pawn moves
i mean he could have waited in reserved
kept uh initial guessing whether you
know he would push that pawn two squares
maybe he would create a passport in a
different angle it wasn't necessary
you know i just really really hate this
decision if levon doesn't win this game
it's because he pushed this pawn two
squares forward
imagine if he could get the same
position
just with his pawn two squares back and
he could slide across with a rook check
kicking away the black king he would
just win this game immediately and now
uh okay he's advanced this rook to a
really nice square but how is he ever
going to kick this black king away these
two pieces are kind of fixed on this
squares forever opposite color bishops
you can't conquer the dark squares and
now because you pushed this pawn as
you've mentioned
um you push this f pawn you simply can't
push the g pawn next to it and uh you
can't break through you can't create a
past pawn so um yeah i think live on
iranian he might have blown his winning
chances anishigiri meanwhile setting the
traps uh if the white king steps forward
maybe there'll be a rook check and
suddenly black is the one winning a
piece black might be the one winning
this game
so yeah it's all going wrong for levon
aronian a true grinder a true end game
expert i think here um of course he's an
in-game expert but a true kind of um
patient
kind of uh player here who loves
squeezing out these advantages would
never push this pawn
and yeah here we go anish giri
in the current position just retreating
as bishop this is maximum fortress for
him it's all about these two squares and
he's defended them
he's consolidated them yeah absolutely
and okay so lavon is going to try i mean
i can see one
idea potentially to break down the
fortress and that's just simply to
relocate the bishop move it on to
another target to the g6 pawn but black
black's work is active black's work is
extremely active and i think this is the
key two defensive pieces are great but
you need one active piece to keep your
opponent honest to keep your opponent
from uh
kind of setting up the ideal structure
the ideal setup and this black rook is
gonna tie white down to this pawn it's
gonna tie white's rook down to the
defense of this bishop
what else can you do and again if we
catch up with the play
i just don't see how white is ever gonna
win this game maybe you could imagine
the white rook coming the whole way
across and behind and round like a
snake
so i would stop this simply i would move
the black rook back guard the eighth
rank and white is not doing anything all
about the snakes in this game yep and uh
the king tucks itself away and i i like
david's uh suggestion for for lavon it
right it reminded me of those old nokia
games oh
he doesn't do that now has he allowed
the rook round has he allowed this rook
uh you mentioned the nokia games this is
uh exactly what
level nurian would want to do right now
if the rook ends up on this square if
the rook ends up on the f7 square
mate whoa
so it takes a while maybe the black rook
will attack the white bishop in the
meantime maybe it's difficult to set up
but
already anishigiri with this last move
may be showing a slight lack of danger
uh alertness
we will see is levon ironian going to
try and come around now with his rook
i don't see a win though for white yet
if the rook does come up maybe uh aiming
to come around black's rook will simply
sidestep hitting this bishop
i agree with you yonko when david made
his arrows with the rook it looked like
the snake came on the nokia 32 something
let me say 10. 32.10 it was my first
phone actually awesome yeah
it's also my first phone as well
great memories actually yeah okay
and
well
levon did try to put his rook on the
eighth rank but
anisha simply attacked the bishop and
levon just moved it back that's not
really progress oh what do you think
ivanka are we going to see a hundred
move game yes yes
they're grinding like grandmasters
that's uh knuckling down trying to
squeeze out the win here for levon
ironian if he can grind out this win
that would be a huge momentum changer
for him
on the first day
i ground out a win in may it was so much
fun i couldn't believe it i was sat
there going oh my goodness me
i got so into it i forgot that it wasn't
optimum that i beat my opponent
oh because it was the first because i i
play for a team in the
national league and i was playing for
the second team and i was playing and i
was playing against my first team
and they would have won that yeah it was
terrible that's how i did to them you
know they they would have won like the
whole league
if i hadn't done
if i hadn't got so into the spirit or
grinding well um anyway but beating a
grand master it's worth it right yeah
well i didn't think about winning i just
thought about pushing my opponent to the
limit that was it i did not think at all
i was like okay what are you gonna do
and then oh maybe he has a draw oh no no
but what happens if he does this and
then i got such a buzz from it i can
imagine it must be the best way to win
and the worst way to lose those grinding
games like game six and the world
championship match yeah it's definitely
the most satisfying feeling in the world
when you feel you've earned it
physically mentally sat there for six
hours squeezed out the win uh but yeah
if you lose one of those games it's
soul destroying uh for sure and i think
that's the case for these two players
right now if aronian wins it it's gonna
be the most satisfying thing in the
world for him maybe that will give him
the confidence boost to win the whole
tournament
but it would be devastating for anish
giri uh just to lose this especially
after fighting his way back from the
brink anishiri was gone he was dead and
buried just
20 25 moves ago suddenly he's defending
a position where
maybe miracles do exist maybe fortresses
uh
you know like this one where white can't
break through on dark squares maybe
fortresses do exist as well
and
right now big big threat on the board
black's rook wanted to go and take this
white pawn on the e6 square white's fire
advanced pawn so that was defended by
levon ironian but the black king now can
come back where it came from maybe
there we go and it will do and it's very
important for black just to simply hold
the balance
not get any not get ambitious not try to
take any pawns just keep holding the
position tight and don't break the
patterns and the nature only has 30
seconds on on the clock is it difficult
for him to defend this
well i think the good thing for anish is
that he's had around 30 seconds for a
long time now
so he's in the rhythm of playing with
little time on his clock
if he just reached this end game with 30
seconds now
then maybe it would take him a while to
kind of acclimatize getting the right
mindset to defend but
i think he's been doing a good job with
little time he's still a trap in the
position and white has to be
a little bit
awake here and uh can't be too energetic
with the rook and put it on a dark
square
because
that would have been a little bit
unpleasant yeah just to show that you
could never
relax too early if white's rook had
moved across for example defending its
bishop then after the black bishop comes
forward the white rook moving then
suddenly whoops black is the one
checkmating the white king white's king
is actually really badly placed this is
a good example of that
but of course levon aronian didn't fall
it for that one if we catch up with the
game then we see still the status quo
has been maintained um this black bishop
uh and this black king are the star
players at the moment they are defending
everything and it's all about this white
structure again why did you put these
pawns on squares where they're blockaded
by the opponent's pawns if levon aronian
could have any move in the world he
would love to move this pawn backwards
but pawns don't move backwards if he
could push this pawn back one square
then he's able to push the pawn next to
it yeah this is why i think committing
he could have played around for 40 moves
tried to find a plan and then committed
this pawn but
i just think that was a hasty decision
and
he stopped to think too late
i think anish giri's going to save this
now what do you think yeah i think
there's a very good chance
that he will save it even despite
the clock situation because it's so easy
just to maintain the balance to maintain
the status quo the king is just going to
step forward
he can't do anything else and then the
rook is just going to slide and you know
he has to be a little bit on his toes
you know he has to be aware of white's
tricks
but
because the position is so empty it
should be quite easy to spot them and
the rook comes
getting ready to give a few more checks
to the white key
also at this point we have to talk about
the 50 move rule ah the last time a pawn
push was made or a capture
and that was on move 46 for white so
already it's been 21 moves since the
last
what we call progress was made no pawn
pushes no captures for 21 moves already
so another 29 moves without any of those
things happening anishikari will save
the draw the 50 mover will kick into
effect maybe now is the time for the
rook to go up to the top of the board
and try to snake its way towards those
pawns on the right yeah i think you have
to right yeah you have to try something
yeah otherwise you're not breaking
through
and uh is it
okay
he pauses anish giri frowned as soon as
that move was made maybe he was scared
of the white rook coming up to the top
of the board do you think that's on
aronia's radar kind of that snake-like
effect coming around because
he seemed like the performance he did it
once but then he kind of
turned back and changed his mind
so
and anish just keeps on allowing it
so then maybe they've just
worked out no problems
yeah i think anish geary's defensive
idea is to just continuously check the
white king with the black rook or to
attack the white bishop with his rook as
well that's the key having two defensive
pieces and one active piece attacking
piece uh black's rook is
really annoying for white to deal with
a rook trade though remember will just
end the game in a draw
so
black's best piece the rook cannot be
exchanged that's what's so frustrating
for iranian and anishigiri he's gained a
bit of time nearly up to one minute
he's surviving he is surviving uh but a
bunch of players has not survived in
round four it was a win for hans niemann
against aryanthari a win for sam sevion
against his fellow american they are
both 21 years old jeffrey chong who won
all of his first three games a loss in
the final round a win for joo and jun
the only female player in the tournament
against timor ajabov and the win for
richard report against the youngest
player
arjun ergaizi so so far all games have
ended with a winner but this one
ah
i'm still thinking anisha's going to
draw this at the beginning of this end
game i said nearly no chance because i
thought aronian would just tease him
create threats slowly
time the breakthrough at the right
moment but yeah i'm just going back to
this one pawn push the last pawn push
that we saw back on move 46
white f-pawn stepping forward
that was the key moment and now we've
gone round in circles for the last 20
plus moves and zero progress at all for
iranian he knows it as well i think
haronian he knows he's blown a big big
opportunity
look how focused geary is though if he
defends this game then
massive massive credit to him
there could be a momentum changer for
him as well yeah that's also a really
satisfying feeling when you knuckle down
you know that your back's against the
wall you know you're struggling and you
save the game
that feels as good as a win sometimes
yeah and actually on the reverse when
you're in that situation you let the
wind slip it also feels
terrible imagine yeah it's uh
because you've got no one this is the
beauty of the chest you've got no one to
blame but yourself
you can take full responsibility for
what you play over the board and the
decisions you make and the time you use
so um yeah it is quite brutal yeah you
need some uh you need some inner
strength to start playing chess top
level
yeah i mean it is brutal because there's
no dice involved you know if i had some
dice we could kind of say wow you know
that fault but no as it stands
yeah but it's fun at the same time
because when you do win you get such a
buzz you also can only blame yourself
yeah exactly i mean yeah okay maybe you
were losing but then you set one final
trap and even even so you keep pushing
yourself to the limits and the beauty of
chess is that every single position is
different yeah and
you're always forced to work yeah
and
well
not much happening lavon is just
maneuvering his rook and bishop around
you know trying to find some way
just to break through i mean i i've been
told by many
in-game specialists this is a good
strategy you just kind of bore your
opponent to death you kind of love them
into some false sense of awareness and
then you pounce with your trick yeah
in general that's a very good strategy
but level around he should have done
that before pushing his left pawn you
might not just maneuver round and round
and round and then push upon one square
and then maneuver around then push up
all the second square then you can
torture your opponent forever also this
is the last game of the day it's not as
if iranian wanted to win quickly to save
energy for later on he can sleep after
this game he should have
been kind of trying to grind it out a
bit earlier i think he only switched to
grinding mode now
in order to win this game because he had
to he thought he could just win directly
he could do anything
but uh and he is such a good defender
anish i mean he
he had this reputation for a while for a
while of drawing a lot of games but
that's just because he was so good at
defending
and uh well while these two experienced
players are grinding this game out we're
going to talk to one of the younger
players and debutante on the tour sam
sevian congratulations with finishing
off with a win today
thank you
what has today been like how will you
sum it up your first tournament on the
tour
uh it's been really exciting um i've
been looking forward to playing this for
a couple of years now and it's great to
get a chance
my first game i was completely winning
and i kind of botched it at the end when
we both had no time but i still felt
like i was playing really well
and kept the form going the next three
games
fantastic and uh with two wins you are
currently in second place the only
player above you is your fellow american
uh jeffrey with uh nine points what's up
with you young americans today
i mean we've always been pretty good at
rapid at shorter time controls been
playing it since eight nine years old so
it's not really a surprise to me
i like to hear that and i have to tell
you according to the guy who does all
our stats you are now
one of the players one of the four
players most likely to make it to the
knockouts are you already thinking about
that or will you just focus on the games
coming tomorrow
well i mean this was just my first day i
do want to continue playing good chess
and
i'll think about that on fourth day
fantastic and i want to mention um i
talked to you before the tournament we
talked about the 50th anniversary of the
match where bobby fischer became world
champion that anniversary is tomorrow so
as an american really feel a little bit
extra inspired tomorrow
oh yeah for sure i mean especially with
the rules this tournament has it rewards
winning more than drawing a couple games
i will definitely be ready for the fight
we wish you best of luck tomorrow as
well sam thank you for joining us
thank you
and we're also going to talk to jeffrey
chong first of all is there any changes
in the game david uh in a word kaya
the grind continues ground continues so
we are joined by jeffrey who is
in seoul lead so far in the tournament
with nine points maybe a little bit
disappointed after the first the final
game here but how will you sum up today
jeffrey
uh yeah obviously it was a great day um
definitely couldn't have asked for
better starting with two blacks and then
was able to get some chances and convert
those so yeah
obviously last game
was uh maybe
shouldn't really shouldn't have lost
that but
that's uh that's how it goes
and starting the day with a win against
one of the top players in the world
danish geary how much inspiration did
that give you
oh yeah definitely i mean
any any win honestly in this event
especially the first one of the day
just carries um carries over to the next
i think but uh definitely against anish
with black uh fella even better are you
surprised with your performance today we
just talked to sam and and he told us
that no no we've known this for many
years even if we haven't played in the
tour before we know that we can play
great in this format so did you feel
this was coming or are you a little bit
surprised about your performance
oh yeah i mean to echo a little bit what
sam said him and i we've been you know
playing a lot of rapid even training
together
uh before so we're definitely quite
experienced and feel that we're well
suited in the fastest time controls but
that being said i mean today was was
certainly a great day for both of us
and heading into day two uh probably in
seoul lead will that put any pressure on
you how will you cope with that
uh not really i mean i think it's still
very early it's just day one um
i think there's what 11 rounds left so a
lot can happen and just hoping to to
keep me going have you enjoyed today has
it been uh fun
oh yeah for sure right this event i mean
i've also followed it many times and
it's certainly very exciting so to to be
a part of it uh it's it's great
and i did ask sam and i'll ask you again
tomorrow being the 50th anniversary of
the 1972 match when bobby fischer became
world champion as an american will you
feel some extra inspiration playing
tomorrow
uh now that you told me i probably will
yeah
i mean bobby he's
arguably uh the best american ever and
certainly if if i can uh try and channel
some of his play i'll try my best to do
it are you um inspired by him is he one
of the players that you find some
inspiration in the style he had the way
he attacked the game
i mean obviously i've
seen a lot of uh his examples but i
can't say that he was truly you know the
most
um
how say like the main guy for me the
main role model i think i had some other
players even
um out of americans i'd probably
try and model my play off more uh fresh
with the fresh players uh-huh such as
well you know i mean
icaru fabiano
fantastic well that definitely seems to
be working jeffrey congratulations on a
great day and best of luck tomorrow
thanks thank you for joining us
what a day he had jeffrey is in uh sully
right now with nine points
but these two two of them are experian
guys have been struggling a little bit
today
and this grind is still going on can
levon win it well we've jumped in again
at a critical moment we're on move 92
right now
if white's 96th move is made without any
captures without any pawn moves then it
will be a draw level neroni now has
three moves to win a pawn his idea is to
go to the top of the board with the
white bishop to the e8 square and win
the pawn next to the black king
he might be in time this is the big
question imagine if he wins upon one
move before
before that hammer falls and the 50 move
rule happens i think he's going to do it
this is move 94
and a pawn capture has happened
one move before the draw was confirmed
levon aronian he's got a chance now we
saw a porn exchange black's bishop
winning a porn due to a pin against the
white king but one of the black pawns
has fallen and look at anishigiri's face
i think he sensed he was close he was so
close one move away from a draw
and
that can be heartbreaking it should
maybe still be a draw with best play
because white's pawns uh the two pawns
on dark squares are big targets but
all the chances now for ironian to go
around again and grind it out again we
could be here for 150 moves wow
even more suddenly i'm excited i'm
starting to warm up today
we might see 200 moves 200 moves we
might see the longest game on the tour
ever the longest game on the tour ever
david probably knows we've had a couple
of 150-ish
move games
um never close to 200 haven't we don't
think close to 200 yet that's very very
rare interest
meanwhile big big moment for
anishigiri can he defend the problem for
black is his remaining pawn black's pawn
is on a light square could just fall
um i think ironian wants to win that
if he can for free he doesn't want to
give up one of his own white pawns for
the black pawn
so he has to be a bit clever if you take
it now one of your own white pawns drops
yeah there's a big kind of trick right
in the right kind of circumstance say
for instance if white were to if we can
pull up the board and just
say you grab the pawn with your bishop
and black takes
okay so maybe you can even do it here
yeah you might be able to go rook takes
pawn and then you just give up after
bishop takes rook king takes and then k
and then now you take the pawn and then
you just rush as quickly as you can to
the corner of the board and there
despite white being a bishop and a pawn
up because it's the wrong color
bishop for that corner it's just a draw
yeah there's no way to budge the king
off the dark squares
exactly due to stalemate ideas this king
will stay nestled in the corner forever
and yeah you're right there ivanka that
would have ended in an immediate draw if
he had grabbed this pawn and look out
for that to happen all the time um yeah
that kind of scenario where it's bishop
and uh kind of pawn of the wrong color
wrong promotion square it will be a draw
so that's the problem for levon ironian
he can win a pawn but he's got to avoid
this end game forever it's going to be a
constant theme so watch out for that one
uh as ivanka mentioned this idea of the
rook at some point uh at some point
taking this pawn um not that pawn i have
me and my arrows again uh this pawn
so yeah right now iranian has to deal
with this in the correct way i like what
anishigiri has done actually he's put
his rook on a defended square defended
by his bishop and this is important
because for example after a rook check
if the king steps forward another rook
check black can actually safely walk
into the firing line and take this pawn
normally you can never ever dream of
walking into a discovered check
but when the rook moves yes it's a check
you move your king suddenly we see why
it's important to defend your rook
because now this would just be a fair
rook trade
you need to make sure you win material
for free here and look at the evaluation
but it says 0.0 oh or 0.1 despite the
fact white has two extra pawns that
means anishgiri has found the ideal
drawing setup he's using these pieces to
defend each other on dark squares both
pointing towards this pawn
and meanwhile the white piece is
just clumsy they can't get back in the
game without allowing that that
nice trick and uh now we have a
situation what is white going to do with
the rook
i mean it's under attack you have to
keep an eye whoa
what is this
i mean can you just grab that rook
ivanka we're gonna see that end game uh
that you mentioned i think
yeah oh actually maybe not the black
king now steps back i was gonna say he
could go for that end game but white's
pawns are not on the h file anymore and
uh level neroni he gave up his rook for
a bishop partly because his rook was
trapped but now white has three pawns
they should easily be stopped though by
the black rook and king
black's rook will stop the white king
from getting active if it can and
black's king will be a great blockader
what do you think though good practical
try he's changed the nature of the
position sometimes that's a good idea
well it's really difficult to see how
how
white is going to actually get the king
active
and king is just stuck on the edge of
the board yeah like white's pawns are
just too closely connected the black
king is doing an amazing job at uh
looking at the both of them
and okay steps back yeah if white's
pawns were further apart so for example
if one white's pawns was on the c file
one on the g file white's king would
have enough space in between them like
you say to sneak through but white's
king does not have enough space between
the two sets of pawns
to march through so and look at what
anish giri's doing that's a great
technique cutting off the white king
from stepping back now
and
i think judging by his previous moves
he's going to step the black rook up to
the fifth rank to stop the white king
marching forward again
um but yeah at this point it should be a
draw black's king war blockade on the
dark squares black's rook will cut off
the white king
or eternity yeah well these two are
grinding and i'm just going to remind
you this is the first tournament in our
ftx summer of chess and
the best fan experience you get if you
sign up for our free
key and on the bottom of the screen is a
qr code or you can head to
ftxcryptocup.com to sign up for your
free key and join a community with a
bunch of
competitions a bunch of exclusive
content
prices up to a hundred thousand dollars
so go ahead and sign up to join in the
community
all right
any chances for lavon here i
think not i think not also i was just
wondering is this one of those end games
where you could just give up the
the rook and kind of
in some situations maybe um
but okay you need to get rid of one of
one of the double double pawns right
possibly yeah i don't think you can give
up your rook for any of the pawns right
now um there wouldn't be enough
stalemating ideas in the position but
the key is that the white king's just
never stepping forward
okay i'm slightly surprised by this one
because now the white king can step one
square forward
uh but the problem is when the white
king steps forward the black rook's just
going to check from behind and there's
nowhere safe to run
and there's nowhere to hide as well you
can run but you can't hide as the song
says i don't know what song was that
oh we need simon with us to tell us yeah
we do simon is the fountain of all
knowledge when it comes to songs and you
you as well
me less so
unless it's 90s pop
and yeah the white king has no safe
haven and look at levon ironian's body
language
he's accepting the fact he's coming to
terms with the fact that there's no way
to win anymore the white king has no
and he gives up one of the pawns i mean
two were basically the same as one there
those two double pawns weren't so
effective but still no way to win this
one okay the bishop retreats anishigiri
though
i want to say this is really instructive
ever since he got down to this end game
which was nearly losing he has barely
looked away from the screen he's been so
focused he's just been a model a model
of concentration
and that's what you need to do when
you're grinding out difficult end games
when you're trying to save the draw uh
from difficult positions
yeah
and he's so close now all he needs to do
is get rid of the two remaining white
pawns even at the cost of the black rook
that's a draw and just look at the king
and the rook such sterling defenders
both of them working in team in tandem
just to just to stop those advances of
those pawns i mean i don't think there's
anything that levong can even dream of
trying
okay so he steps forward with the king
okay well that's going to get checked
away yeah and he was shaking his head he
knows that there's no way forward
anymore
now black's rook can simply go back to
attack the white pawn uh the very far
advanced white e pawn
the black king can maybe just attack
that pawn as well
yeah that's uh also looks great
black rook can just slide back
stopping the white bishop from using
some squares
that was also appealing to me as well so
okay the king steps forward
yeah
bishop defends okay now can you just
harass the bishop
yes i think because the bishop has no
more
kind of fortified squares it has no safe
yeah safe squares to use it's just too
loose you just keep attacking it attack
this bishop now
pin down the white king tie down the
white king to defending its bishop there
we go
the white king can't move so the bishop
had two and now black just needs to
bring the rook to any safe square it's
attacked right now
i think any safe square will do
and now yeah this one it's a guaranteed
draw i think ah
wow that was a very key moment there
that uh the rook tied down and you're
gonna see it there once again the rook
is tying down the white king the white
king is not allowed to be an attacker
and i
move the rook again
attack the bishop
exactly and she's been so accurate i
think for the last
what is it 70 moves at this point ever
since he got this end game with two
pawns down he's defended like a lion and
this one is about to be a draw give
another check the white king has nowhere
to hide don't allow white to push the
g-pawn forward
that would still be a draw but more work
to do
just keep checking
yeah why not and now just uh attack the
bishop
yeah
check or attack the bishop both will do
just attack something yeah that's the
key when in doubt attack something he
attacks the king
forces the king back
but uh
but now is
maybe now you could consider taking off
the white pawn with your rook
i think that is a draw just about
because you because the black king gets
to the critical g7 square yeah so i
think we'll see this on the board uh
yeah
plays it eliminate and this is why you
need to study your end games you need to
know exactly what end games are drawn
and which ones aren't and we're going to
see stalemate one point alone is not
enough and ishqiri smiles
saves the draw
he finishes the day with a smile in each
gear but this basically sums up a really
bad day a bad first day in the
tournament for both levon aronian and
the nishkiri to of the very top
favorites but
they've lost some games today and
struggled